[Music]
so there's this crazy thing that
happened in india if you follow joe
rogan you might have seen him post about
it
uh i can't even believe he posted this
but
uh there was like a nature like a
national park in india where these four
guys
uh trespassed into that area
and there's an animal called a monitor
lizard which is like a oh it's a big
lizard guy yeah it's a big lizard that's
protected like it's you know they're
it's it's not like uh it's almost
endangered i think it's as big as like a
komodo dragon like no i don't think it's
that big
yeah so how big how big
um this will give you an idea of how big
okay so four men were accused of gang
raping
killing and then cooking and eating the
lizard why i don't know how big it is
oh it's big enough to rape kill and cook
for four men why is it why is their
first
idea to let me stick my dick in the
lizards who wants to rape a lizard who
doesn't have sex with you gotta be a bet
like they bet they lost a bet and
they're like you guys gotta do it you
said it this is what the the native
americans do but at a higher level
higher level because they only
hunt cook eat and use it right yeah they
did all of that and they [ __ ] it and
they okay and they made a purse out of
the skin maybe they elevated it see what
you're doing maximize is maximizing
because a native american didn't [ __ ]
the buffalo so these guys were like you
know what we gotta one up it by [ __ ]
the komodo dragon how does this but the
thing is like did someone catch them how
does this get confused here's here's how
it happened so this um the it's called
the
sayadri tiger reserve and there's
cameras there and they saw video of
these guys trespassing the area so when
they arrested them like hey you guys can
be trespassing what did you do here did
you steal anything so they looked in
their phones they found photos and video
of the entire thing no
and they were able to confirm that uh
these guys didn't do it for any
religious reason for any ritualistic
thing they did it purely for fun
that's a for fun crime they get horny
from lizards that's really weird maybe
it's it's like indian indian jackass bro
frat [ __ ]
how do you be like it's like that's what
they do is like you know what let's
yo bros like let's go [ __ ] a lizard
they're like no bro that is so wild how
do you even find a hole to have sex with
the lizard the thing that's the thing
that that like bothers my mind is how do
you find three other people that are
also exactly that are into it like
you're into this
like you want to go four of them [ __ ]
this lizard [ __ ] i want to see what
that looks like okay there's gotta be
one guy amongst them that was like ah
man i don't know
i wanna do this like come on
you're always a big party pooper
all right here comes the [ __ ] look like
i don't know you'll see in a second i've
never looked down there
oh
it's so small and then they cooked it
and ate it and it's surprised a human
can fit at least they ate it that's
oh
i mean that's a lizard [ __ ] it's not
like oh can't we should [ __ ] that way
it's a lizard vagina from a different
lizard there's no monitor lizard vagina
on what is the monitor lizard look
can we pull that up yeah that's crazy
dude
it kind of just looks like a big lizard
let's see i don't get horny off of
reptiles
mammals maybe but reptiles bro
who wants to [ __ ] that bro
other monitor religions hopefully
objectively who else yeah they're going
to come out with a new version of coven
now aren't they in danger a fleshlight
yeah
are these uh monitor lizards are they in
danger they're i believe they are uh
they're protected which i think means
they're almost yeah they weren't that
protected because [ __ ] dude
right here they didn't protect them at
all
they just let these guys come in and
[ __ ] the [ __ ] how do you how do you run
a reserve like that and just let guys
[ __ ] your lizard you know
crazy that's [ __ ] weird maybe they
think about their security detail a
little bit yeah like because you know
like the the chopping up killing and
cooking like to me that's like oh that
sucks too but it also is like pretty
humid to just
catch an animal cook it right and eat it
fine even if it's a gross creature
people do it all over the world
but i don't know anybody that [ __ ]
their food before they eat it yeah
that's that's that's next level can you
imagine if you found four dudes in your
backyard [ __ ] or dog or something
they're all getting murdered they have
to all get murdered they're all gonna
get [ __ ] up for sure like they have to
get killed the guy must be so furious
the guy that owns this lizard
yeah like oh my god that's so crazy yeah
i want to see what these guys look like
yeah what do they look like oh they're
like lizards
they're like lizard manuals
it's implanted into his eyebrows
they're not men they're lizards if they
were lizard guys i'd be like all right
all right you kind of committed your
life you're the villain for spider-man
all right like animorphs yeah yeah yeah
when did you [ __ ] the lizard when you
were fully the lizard or when you were
the human or were you halfway through
get into the mode man i just stayed
human
[ __ ] up it was just reptilian dudes
you know when you're a cop and you're
watching those videos
you can't even really fast forward right
because you're gonna cause you're
looking for evidence you're seeing what
else are they doing that's what i was
thinking so you can't even go like okay
i get the gist of it um you guys are
disgusting you have to go okay every
single second what the [ __ ] even even it
would just be like looking at it and
looking at them like
wait that was you guys
why why
even worse is that in court the jury
will have to watch every second of that
too
oh
that's how you have to like look at uh
there's evidence like that but this is
like not court here this is indian court
so how does like india court work yeah
it might be different you know they make
the lizard testify
there's a key witness lizard that was
watching the whole thing [ __ ] that's so
disgusting that loser just points its
tongue
is he in the room right now
i don't know how they [ __ ] do it
i think that's pretty good there is a
picture that i'm gonna find it yeah i
want to see what yeah
basically like if if court over there's
anything like here it's the same way
where if uh because i had a friend who
uh was accused of rape
and he actually uh secretly recorded
having sex with this girl that said uh
raped her
so when he presented that that evidence
in court his family the jury everyone
had to watch the entire video beginning
to end to make sure that at no point did
she say no damn that's crazy so he said
that's like the worst trade-off he's
ever like to be exonerated from a crime
but yet your whole family has to see you
all the time but he it was all good
though like he didn't get popped no
because she was lying the whole video is
like yeah i want more yeah yeah yeah the
boy laid it down
there's never been no in this whole
video with his dad like
three minutes only
you are not my son
[Laughter]
oh my gosh let me fly the picture of
these he kept saying i'm sorry while
they're [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm usually
not like this
or he's the one saying no yeah he's like
no
yeah
dude yeah it's crazy that i didn't know
they do that that chick's [ __ ] up
accusing him for a rape that's why she
cheated on her boyfriend and wanted like
she got caught so that she was like oh i
don't wanna not that that's a good thing
everyone does but like but in this case
yeah in this case that's what happened
and she didn't want the shame of like oh
you know
so i don't understand why the [ __ ] this
is a thing
but they took pictures with the guys
when they arrested them and it looks
like
it looks like group photos i can't get
them over the ship why
like with the cops yeah
like they're proud of them so the guys
on the floor these are the there's
that's three of them and the fourth guy
i think is in blue
or yeah is that a guy wearing a
two-toned shirt is this the fourth guy
i think so because it says it's like why
is he just chilling like it's like
with the cops we don't even have cuffs
on it but like here this is yeah the guy
in yellow red blue and then the
two-toned shirt guy they just do things
different out there dude i remember
these guys they caught these criminals
right and then to bring them out for the
press to see they [ __ ] held their
hand and then they all walked out and
they were just standing there holding
their hand like children so they're like
red rovers yeah so like the bad guys and
the cops were all [ __ ] holding hands
like like this and then they're doing
the photo op and then they had to bring
them back
yeah that's weird yeah yeah it's pretty
interesting because it looks like
straight up just chilling after green
barbecue they're hanging out
it looks like a [ __ ] squad photo dude
with the boys
it's so interesting how countries do
things huh yeah different countries
different countries man they mean
different things and then i mean of
course like india is pretty [ __ ]
pissed about it because they're like
damn of all the things that make
international news like this [ __ ]
you know like what a whack
representation but like of course you're
gonna hear idiots be like yeah see i
told you india is [ __ ] weird yeah
dude you're gonna pick that out of like
one of those heavily popular i mean if
they got a billion people i know you're
there's gonna be a lot of weird there's
gonna be some lizard [ __ ] in there
you know but they're like anyone but joe
rogan posted about that i know that's
what's crazy because i was like joe no
because that headline is crazy it's
crazy you read it you're like
logistically i want to know how it's
happening it's like if it's non-indian
publications they're always going to
point out that they're indian you know
like in the headlines straight up for
indian men yeah
damn that's pretty bad i mean damn yeah
so it's a little [ __ ] but
don't let that change your view on
anything dude what do peta say about
that [ __ ] they're like this is wrong i
believe any problem this huge would be
above peta's efforts and reach
damn i think everyone's like yeah we're
with you on this one peter
lock these dudes up he's not gonna be
able to do anything about that
how do you [ __ ] a lizard that's so crazy
did they find each other on like some
kind of forum for like
lizardfuckers.com that life have you
ever fet life was fed life it's uh it's
like social media platform for people
with fetishes to connect fetlock
so you like you you input the thing your
kinks
and then it like links you with other
people that and then you just have
casual hookups
i thought that was pretty cool i learned
that on soft white underbelly
that's kind of fire there was there was
this girl in softlight underbelly being
interviewed and she was uh like a sex
addict and they were asking her like
like she said she had sex with like 10
random people per week and they were
like where do you find these people and
she goes phet life everyone just finds
them on that
i was like what is this i looked it up i
was like oh [ __ ] it's real wow so i'm
sure something like this i mean i'm
pretty sure that's not how they met each
other but so the lizard has a fat life
account
pull up guys
the lizard wanted me
he just didn't know that they would take
it that far but it's like a one-shot
fantasy it's like i could do this and
then i'll be dead but is there is there
some stories about cannibalism that like
uh people that did that they're like oh
i want to get
chopped up
there have been cases where dudes uh got
their dick cut off and fed to them yeah
and they want that they want that
they're into that it's exhilarating
well we can't ask the lizard now if they
wanted it or not because
they're kind of gone
you